violence speed momentum oh yeah
dynamic gaming athlete doctor disrespect
here for the score esports esports to
you it's a little friendly competition a
little fun for mere mortals while
eSports can be pretty scary too not as
scary spacing down the dock in a 1v1
with the circle closing in around your
neck but pretty scary
[Music]
that's why we're bringing you the top 10
scariest ways to die in eSports brought
to you by the two-time 1993-1994
blockbuster video game champ we're
starting this list off with what has to
be the worst way to die since I don't
know a xenomorph chest burster I'm
talking about getting killed while
crossing mid doors on dust2
get all three okay what is this done
it's on a diamond through the door
think about it it's the beginning of the
round you smoked doors you even jumped
over the gap and some Teesside monster
takes your head off before you get
anywhere near the B site now mere
seconds into the round you are a player
down your economy is wrecked and you're
too scared to ever go back to B what a
nightmare
alright look guys dying to the likes of
Roshan or Baron is scary enough but
dying to a jungle creep well that's a
horror story all in its own he's nervous
to eat it to know either number 9 on our
list are those pesky jungle creeps from
both dota 2 and League of Legends who
are way scarier than you probably give
them credit for whether you were farming
or trying to Juke an enemy pursuer the
previously laughable jungle creeps
become infinitely scarier when you're
low on health
all the grapes are number eight entry
has to be one of the most horrific ways
to go in counter-strike no matter what
map you're playing getting knifed in the
back see holding an angle in
counter-strike demands intense
concentration from the player it's easy
to tunnel vision onto a single line of
sight I mean you've got teammates
holding the flank allowing you to scope
in and focus waiting for an enemy's head
to pop out but suddenly you hear that
unmistakable groan of death
not only has your round ended in
embarrassment but the paranoia in the
following rounds will haunt you for the
rest of the game Oh almost but not Oh
you heartless creature if you've ever
played dota 2 then there's no doubt
you've encountered the feeling of pure
dread that accompanies our number seven
entries
as far as killing again you're minding
your own business farming in lane but
suddenly out of the fog of war through
the treeline the dreaded meathook flies
out snatching you into the clutches of
the butcher himself fresh mate and as if
getting pulled into a toxic cloud is it
terrifying enough Pudge follows it up by
dismembering and eating his victim gross
League of Legends is a game that
revolves around vision after all if you
can see what's going on there's nothing
to be afraid of right
but when Nocturne reaches level 6 the
horror show begins as the eternal
nightmare himself instills fear in enemy
champions by applying near sight
to reduce vision with his alt the aptly
named paranoia anyone who's ever been
the victim of a Nocturne alt knows just
how scary it is when darkness falls and
the gank is on the smoke grenade is one
of the most important pieces of utility
in csgo
it completely obstruct vision of an area
and wraps you in a cozy blanket of
safety if you're holding a sight that is
unless you're up against Stewie 2k then
the smoke becomes your worst enemy in
our number 5 entry just when you think
that dark cloud will keep you safe the
smoke criminal himself runs out and
domes you in the head driving you into a
state of shock confusion and frustration
Stewie's got him down top since he's
been silenced in this game Stewie goes
through good flash smoke criminal
strikes again
it takes a certain level of confidence
to facecheck a bush you have a Gallio to
face check this why is turtle just
wandering in walks back into the side
after all you can never truly be sure of
who or what is in there unless you've
got some vision and that's why the
terror of the face check comes in at
number four on our list
uh-oh it's a foggy Vulcan they're gonna
get the face I've been jumping on the
balls and he explodes our first blood
maybe there's a rain garden to pounce or
maybe a threshold
it's a dangerous task but one that must
be done and the scariest fate of them
all is to meet the entire enemy team no
level of bravery is going to save you
from 5e low thirsty champions this is
good parents on that pink automatic
they're being very aggressive on this
one I don't know if the other team noses
it looks like they could walk right into
a leasing could be the first one here
doublelift walking right to the bushy
will face check this and he could be
going down he is absolutely going down
few players have survived to tell the
tale of being trapped in the corner by
Tokyo's Akuma
and finals of evil which is why the
terrifying prospect lands in at number
three on our list it's scary enough just
to be going up against the murderface
himself but the true terror is when he's
got you backed into the corner now he
has corner control naturally the Akuma
player instills fear into his opponents
but even more so when there's nowhere
left to run all that meter now for those
F ABC combos corner carry oh did he just
know this is how it all goes south park'
Brad is gonna be busy and that oh no the
murderface too early our runner-up entry
is a Rainbow six siege attackers worst
nightmare it's when the hunter becomes
the hunted it's getting interrogated by
kuvira where's the rest of you let's go
with her predatory technique that lowers
the sound of her footsteps and a custom
pistol that fires subsonic rounds calves
kit makes her one of the sneakiest
operators in siege and if she happens to
catch you alone not only will she kill
you but she'll reveal the position of
the rest of your team bringing
consequence even after death were kurz
are perhaps the most important units in
StarCraft after all they are the ones
gathering the resources upon which your
entire army is built so wouldn't it be a
shame if something were to happen to
them taking the crown on our list for
the spookiest ways to die is losing your
mineral line to dark Templars these
permanently cloaked assassins are liable
to induce cardiac arrest in any
Starcraft player who doesn't have the
detection to deal with them once you
hear that sickening sound all right well
this is where you can type GG it's
probably too late
that hatchery is forfeit here there's
like a Dewback that's right Cooper's so
he's gonna try and continue on and hold
on but he's gonna lose so many work has
already lost 12 oh boy oh boy oh boy
GG oh yeah I feel the adrenaline pumping
now huh who hosts top ten better than
the doc I'm the best you huh huh you I
don't think so
hit that like button subscribe to the
channel become a champion like me thanks
for watching if you want more great
content just like this be sure to hit
the subscribe button
[Music]